les agriculteurs en france qui disent on
ne peut pas se passer du glyphosate n'en
sait qu'ils ne veulent pas se passer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que ceux qui sont en bio n'utilise
plus de mille feux that et je connais
des agriculteurs qui ne sont pas en bio
qui se passe du glyphosate depuis
plusieurs années et ça fonctionne ces
deux techniques
c'est un autre travail parce que le
glyphosate c'est du bon marché et du
travail rapide c'est ça qu'ils veulent
c'est du confort de travail
or sur le confort du travail on ne peut
pas le faire ou dépend de sa santé
tiens produite comme le glyphosate est
dangereux et à mon avis aujourd'hui il
ya suffisamment d'éléments concordants
pour dire que ce produit dangereux je ne
vois pas un agriculteur dire au nom de
quelconques raison on continue
d'utiliser un produit dangereux pour
l'environnement pour nous agriculteurs
pour les riverains et pour le
consommateur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu des exploitations en france de
plusieurs centaines à gries d'hectares
en agriculture biologique c'est pas des
gens qui travaillent avec des choux
c'est pas des gens qui s'éclairent à la
bougie ce sont des gens au contraire
très technique très technique et qui est
qu'ils sont qui ont à la fois la
performance agronomiques et économiques
qui en vivent bien et qu'ils sont
capables de faire des produits de
qualité l'agriculteur qu'à 50 ans à
utiliser autour de 900 molécules
différentes dans un service
professionnel je dis ça parce que aussi
des fois on nous dit qu'il ya des
agriculteurs qu'on 90 ans qui sont en
pleine santé faut pas imaginer même
s'ils ont utilisé de vraie saloperie
à un moment donné que c'est eux qui ont
été les plus exposés ceux qu'on est les
plus exposés c'est sont ceux qui ont 50
ans aujourd'hui et j'ai peur j'ai peur
que ceux qui ont 25 et 30 ans ont
l'impression que c'est derrière eux et
qu'aujourd'hui y compris avec le
glyphosate tout va bien on peut on peut
travailler et puis j'entends même que
des fois c'est peut-être un mal
nécessaire
voilà ceux qui sont malades c'est qu'ils
sont plus fragiles depuis les écolos
bobos parisiens ils nous cassent les
pieds non c'est une prise de conscience
qu'on doit avoir collective